one of my favorite uh new artists who
relatively new i mean he's been doing
his thing um but
i love kenny man and you got kenny on
this uh this drop that just this came
out obviously somebody from from atl
yeah somebody who i think somehow it's a
little underappreciated you know um but
is i feel like you're gonna have a crazy
career ahead of them um just talk about
like link it up with kenny man and just
kind of
you know shine some light on on on him
in general because i feel like he's he's
one of them ones as well yeah brushy's
dope um
for real i'm just like a super
fan of like atlanta you know what i'm
saying just just what that whole scene
brings so i'm like super supportive or
whatever even if some people may hate it
or whatever like i'm just super
supportive of what it sounds that's
coming from the city so there's a lot of
uh
up-and-coming artists that i like and i
show love too you know what i'm saying
just because
it needs that light being shine you know
what i'm saying i got
blessed with the opportunity with
somebody like shine a light on me yeah
you got me to this point where i'm
talking to you you know what i'm saying
so i just try and do my part it ain't
even too much thought into it you know
what's right if you're talented like
you're from the city like i'm doing this
it's black and white forever give me
some of the background um
obviously spillage village is uh a crew
before you guys were
everyone was signed yeah you know what
i'm saying you
give me the dynamics because where was
it a house everybody was living in nah
was it shout out to marieba shout out to
black shout out to everybody who's
involved
give me kind of like the breakdown of
like the the roots of spillage village
because it's like almost like y'all are
like low-key like
very reminiscent of the dungeon family
coming out of the a you know what i mean
um it started with me earth king we
literally said hey we should be a
collective you know what i'm saying we
was going to school at the same time
in virginia so
we're in aduba cook for sure
that was amazing i loved that reference
shout out to um shout out to
um but yeah we was all up in through
virginia but i got kicked out of school
so like trying to figure out what's next
let's start this collective like things
really was already rapping together
fakely in the dorms like trying to
figure out
how to put it together but then we said
let's put it together me and earth game
so we started it
and then we had the homies like
hollywood jb and jordan bryant like
they brothers they were just amazing and
then marieba and black was just like we
knew them from the city
did shows around the same type of little
scene we had and then it just all worked
out it was really family you know what
i'm saying we all live in the same house
at a time period we're just sleeping on
couches and stuff like that not marie
but more so because you know i'm saying
[ __ ] lady but all the boys who used to
rough it you know what i'm saying
college dorm room style like now which
is college what's what's like what's
that crib like was you earth gang black
everybody in a crib
is it like everyone's always recording
is it like what's like what is that like
yeah it wasn't like you know what i'm
saying we was moving around we wasn't
just sitting in the house recording so
some days like somebody be on the mic me
i wake up every morning and got right to
it before anybody i'm up six in the
morning with it but everybody was moving
around doing different things and we
just tried to find time to make music
together and then like separately we had
to make our projects to get us
the individual like you know what i'm
saying so
it was
it was kind of organized it was kind of
mature as hell because we knew what he
was going for nah and it worked out i
feel like it i feel like there's not
enough uh
i feel like people don't know that story
enough yeah because if you think about
everybody's really doing their thing
everybody signed everybody like
contour on
was black like the first guy that really
kind of popped off yeah black killed it
free black was [ __ ] classic [ __ ]
insane bro um
and i just saw it in him like i saw the
trajectory of where he was gonna go just
off his work ethic and just how he used
to move around like do you have any
intel on when he's going to put out a
new album because it's been a while
that's right
no i ain't got too much deep man
i'll be on it though i'm going to be on
it
i'll tell you this the lvrn guys have
come through here with like three
artists in the last two months and every
time they come i'm like guys
what's up
what is going on with the black [ __ ] we
need a new i i feel like the last album
was
2019 was it 2018 it might be 18.
yeah i might be 18.
feels like it feels like a while at
least
yeah got to be i think it's 18